Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
THE REMAINING SIX GIRLS
ARRIVED IN TOKYO, JAPAN.
Eva: PINK POSITIVE MAKIN' IT
TO TOKYO TOGETHER, BABY.
Tyra: BUT EXCITEMENT TURNED
TO DREAD DURING THE GIRLS'
FIRST COMMERCIAL SHOOT.
Jay: YOU GIRLS ARE GOING TO
DO THIS COMMERCIAL IN JAPANESE.
- Eva: AH!
- Norelle: NO!
Tyra: ANN ROSE
TO THE CHALLENGE...
Ann: (speaking Japanese)
Translator: PERFECT.
Tyra: WHILE EVA STRUGGLED.
Eva: (speaking Japanese)
Tyra: WHEN THE TABLES
WERE TURNED, EVA PANICKED.
Eva: I HAVE GOOD PICTURES.
I... UP.
SO HOPEFULLY, SOMEONE WITH...
PICTURES... UP.
Tyra: BUT IN THE END, IT WAS
NICOLE WHO WAS SENT HOME.
FIVE GIRLS REMAIN--
YAYA, NORELLE, ANN,
AMANDA, EVA--
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
Amanda: WHEN WE FIRST ARRIVED
IN TOKYO, WE GET
TO THE FONTAINE AKASAKA.
IT'S A BUSINESSMAN'S TRAVELING
CAPSULE HOTEL.
IT'S LIKE REALLY LOW-RENT.
Koko: GOOD MORNING, GIRLS.
IT'S TIME TO WAKE UP.
(speaking Japanese)
YOU HAVE MAIL FROM TYRA.
YOU WANT TO READ IT FOR US?
Yaya: "HOPE YOU ENJOYED YOUR
COZY BEDS, BUT NOW IT'S TIME
"TO STRETCH YOUR LEGS.
"PACK YOUR BAGS
AND GET READY TO GO.
AT 11:00,
A NEW HOME YOU'LL KNOW."
(all cheering)
Eva: THANK GOD
WE GOT TYRA MAIL.
THE EXPECTATIONS
OF OUR HOME IN TOKYO
WERE NOT THE CAPSULE HOTEL.
Yaya: DURING PANEL,
THE CRITIQUES HAVE TO DO
WITH PERFORMANCE.
AND TYRA'S CRITIQUE FOR ME
HAD TO DO WITH CHARACTER.
Tyra: I SUGGEST YOU GO
TO THE NEAREST BAKERY IN JAPAN
AND ORDER UP THE BIGGEST SLICE
OF HUMBLE PIE.
Yaya: I KNOW WHO I AM,
AND I KNOW WHAT KIND
OF REPUTATION I HAVE, BUT I
DIDN'T SHOW THAT TO YOU HERE.
SO I'M GONNA TAKE THAT,
AND I'M GONNA SWALLOW IT.
THANK YOU.
Norelle: I AM SO SURPRISED
I EVEN MADE IT THIS FAR.
WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT,
FOR ME TO BE TOP FIVE?
HOLY CRAP.
Eva: THERE'S FIVE OF US LEFT.
THERE'S GONNA BE FOUR OF US,
AND THE NUMBERS
WILL KEEP GETTING FEWER.
I'M GONNA GIVE ALL MY EFFORT,
ENERGY TO ANYTHING THAT I DO
IN THIS COMPETITION.
Ann: I AM SURPRISED
AT THE WAY MY RELATIONSHIP
WITH EVA HAS CHANGED
AND IT WENT SO FAST,
AND IT'S LIKE,
WE IMMEDIATELY CLICKED.
Eva: TOAST TO THE TOP TWO.
Ann: LET'S GET HER DONE.
Eva: (screams)
Ann: YOU'LL BE IN MY WEDDING,
LIKE, I SWEAR TO GOD.
LIKE, I LOVE YOU.
I KNOW THAT PEOPLE MIGHT THINK
I'M IN EVA'S SHADOW.
I'M NOT.
MY OPINION OF EVA HAS CHANGED
DRASTICALLY.
Eva: I HAVE GOOD PICTURES.
I... UP.
SO HOPEFULLY, SOMEONE WITH... UP
PICTURES... UP,
AND THEY GO HOME.
Ann: SO WHO WOULD THAT BE,
ME OR NORELLE?
IT'S REALLY ANNOYING
WHEN YOU KNOW SHE'S GONNA
TAKE A GOOD PICTURE.
YOU KNOW SHE'S GONNA DO WELL.
I HAVE ABSOLUTELY TERRIBLE
PICTURES.
- Koko: EVERYBODY READY?
- All: READY.
Koko: IN JAPAN, WE SAY IKO.
WHEN WE SAY LET'S GO, IKO.
Norelle: IKO, EVA.
Koko: HOW DO YOU FEEL, YOU
GUYS, BEING FIVE PEOPLE NOW?
Eva: AS THE NUMBERS
GET SMALLER,
IT'S HARD TO SEE SOMEONE, LIKE,
SO CLOSE TO THEIR DREAM.
YOU'VE WORKED SO HARD
TO GET HERE.
IT'S, LIKE, FOOTSTEPS AWAY.
AS MUCH AS I WANT IT, TOO,
EVERYONE WANTS IT.
Amanda: I FEEL THAT
A LOT OF OF PEOPLE IN THE HOUSE
DON'T NECESSARILY
WANT TO BE AROUND EVA.
THE HOUSE HAS TO HAVE A TARGET.
THAT'S JUST MOB MENTALITY
AND HUMAN NATURE IN COMPETITION.
Koko: WHO'S YOUR FAVORITE
MODEL, EVA?
Eva: KATE MOSS.
SHE'S LIKE 5'5",
AND SHE'S A SUPERMODEL.
Yaya: SHE'S 5'6".
Eva: SHE'S NOT EVEN 5'6".
NO, SHE'S NOT.
Ann: I FIND MYSELF NOW
LISTENING TO EVA TRY
AND FAKE HER NICENESS.
I KNOW PEOPLE SEE IT.
I KNOW PEOPLE DON'T
'BUY INTO IT.
Eva: WE PULL UP, AND OUR
NEW HOME IS THIS DECKED-OUT,
JAPANESE-STYLE HOME IN TOKYO.
Man: PLEASE LEAVE YOUR BAGS
HERE.
Ann: IT'S SO LOW.
LOOK AT MY HEAD.
Eva: IT'S, LIKE, SO QUIET.
THE ATMOSPHERE
CALLS FOR A CALMING PERSONALITY.
SINCE I'VE GOTTEN HERE IN TOKYO,
MY WHOLE MOOD AND DEMEANOR
IS SO DIFFERENT.
BECAUSE OF THE ENVIRONMENT,
I'VE BEEN MORE RELAXED
AND MORE QUIET.
Man: TWO GIRLS
MAY USE THIS ROOM.
AND THREE GIRLS
Eva: CLEARLY,
THREE PINK POSITIVE.
TWO IS AMANDA AND YAYA.
Yaya: AMANDA AND I
EMULATE THE JAPANESE STYLE.
SO IT'S JUST A WHOLE DIFFERENT
MINDSET THAT WE HAVE.
Kumeo: WE SERVE
JAPANESE COLD TEA,
ESPECIALLY FOR THIS SEASON,
AND ALSO A JAPANESE SWEET.
- Ann: WHAT IS THIS MADE OF?
- Kumeo: FROM BEANS.
Norelle: OH, MY GOD.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND
JAPANESE FOOD.
I DO NOT EAT JAPANESE FOOD.
IF I DO, I EAT,
LIKE, PANDA EXPRESS.
Kumeo: YOU HAVE TO GO
TO FIRST LESSON IN TOKYO.
- Ann: RESTAURANT?
- Kumeo: LESSON.
Ann: LESSON, OH.
Kumeo: AND DON'T BE LATE,
OKAY?
Yaya: YES.
(speaking Japanese)
Yoko: KONNICHIWA.
SIT DOWN.
WELCOME TO OUR TEA HOUSE.
MY NAME IS YOKO TAKAHASHI.
AS A TOP MODEL,
YOU MUST LEARN TO INTERACT
WITH PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD.
TODAY, I'M GOING TO TEACH YOU
THE TEA CEREMONY.
Amanda: AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL HAS TO BE RESPECTFUL
OF THE CULTURE THAT YOU'RE IN.
THE TEA CEREMONY
HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE
FOR THOUSANDS OF YEARS.
IT DOESN'T GET ANY BETTER
THAN THAT.
Norelle: JAPAN AND JAPANESE
ANYTHING, IT'S LIKE SPACE.
LIKE, I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT TO EXPECT.
Yoko: LET'S PRACTICE
HOW TO ENTER THE TEA ROOM.
OPEN A LITTLE BIT,
AND THEN MOVE THE HAND,
OPEN AND CHANGE THE HAND.
A LITTLE LOWER, YES.
NO, HOLD HERE.
Norelle: IS THIS RIGHT?
Yoko: NO, NO, NO.
Norelle: OPENING
A SLIDING DOOR IN JAPAN,
SERIOUSLY TAKES FIVE MINUTES.
Yoko: YES, VERY GOOD.
ONCE AGAIN, PLEASE.
Yoko: SO DON'T DO THAT.
CUT IN ANY TIME.
AFTER YOU FINISH EATING--
YES, THAT'S RIGHT--
FOLD THE PAPER.
Amanda: JUST REALLY GOT
THIS SENSE OF OTHERWORLDLINESS
AND CALM ABOUT ME.
BUT A LOT OF THE GIRLS
AREN'T REALLY ABSORBING
THE CULTURE.
Yoko: THE FRONT SIDE,
THE MOST BEAUTIFUL PART,
FACES THE GUEST.
AFTER WE DRINK,
WE TURN THE TEA BOWL BACK,
APPRECIATE THE TEA.
THE TEA BOWL IS SERVED
OUTSIDE THE BLACK LINE.
THEN SHE TAKES IT INSIDE
THE BLACK LINE
AND OSAKI-NI,
AND THEN PUT IT
IN FRONT OF HERSELF
AND IN SYMBOL TO THE HOST.
THANK YOU FOR THE TEA.
Norelle: (gasps)
THERE IS SO MUCH DETAIL.
YOU THINK OF TEA
LIKE GOING TO YOUR FRIENDS HOUSE
AND HAVING SOME TEA--
WHOO, IT'S NOT.
IT'S SO HARD.
Yaya: NORELLE
SEEMS TO HAVE A BIG AVERSION
TO ANYTHING FOREIGN.
OSAKI-NI.
Yoko: THAT'S VERY GOOD.
Yaya: I TRAVEL THE WORLD,
AND PEOPLE TELL ME ALL THE TIME
HOW RESPECTFUL I AM
AND HOW HUMBLE A PERSON I AM.
Yoko: THAT IS VERY GOOD.
Ann: DO I JUST DO
THE OSAKI-NI?
- Yoko: NO, NO, NO.
- Eva: YOU'RE THE FIRST PERSON.
Ann: OH, I DON'T
HAVE TO DO THAT, OH, OKAY.
Yoko: OSAKI-NI.
NO, NO, NO.
Ann: I THOUGHT
I SAY THAT TO YOU.
Eva: YOU SAY THAT TO ME.
Ann: THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
Eva: WHENEVER ANN SEEMS TO DO
BAD, SHE JUST GETS MAD AT ME.
I DON'T WANT TO USE THE WORD
"JEALOUSY,"
BUT SHE GETS FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE OF THE WAY SHE'S FEELING
ABOUT HER PERFORMANCE.
Amanda: WITH MY BLINDNESS,
I APPRECIATE EVERY SUNRISE,
BUTTERFLY,
THE DEWDROP ON A PETAL,
AND THE SENSEI WAS TALKING
ABOUT APPRECIATING.
AND IT BEING THE ONLY
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT MOMENT.
IT IS SO TRUE.
AND I THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT
I DON'T KNOW IF THE OTHER GIRLS
WILL PICK UP ON.
Eva: I HAD A GREAT RESPECT
FOR LEARNING THEIR RITUALS.
I DEFINITELY WASN'T AS DEEP
AS AMANDA, WHO CRIED.
Yoko: NOW YOU ARE EXPERT.
Norelle: THAT'S ALL
I'M GONNA SAY ABOUT JAPAN
IS IT'S THE MOST DIFFICULT PLACE
I'VE EVER BEEN IN MY LIFE.
- Yoko: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
- Yaya: (speaking Japanese)
Eva: YOU'RE IN A COMPETITION.
THERE'S ONLY A FEW OF US LEFT.
AND AT THIS POINT,
EVERYONE'S STRESSED OUT.
EVERYONE'S TIRED.
Kumeo: EXCUSE ME.
LETTER.
Amanda: OH, THANK YOU.
Eva: THANK YOU.
TYRA MAIL.
"THERE'S MUCH TO LEARN
SURROUNDING THESE THREE.
BE READY AT 9:00."
THREE JAPANESE WORDS.
Ann: MAYBE THOSE
ARE DESSERTS.
Yaya: OH, NO.
MYSTIC TEA CEREMONY.
Ann: THE TYRA MAIL
THAT WE GOT, WE ALL KNEW
THAT WE WERE DOING SOMETHING
WITH A TEA CEREMONY.
- Eva: "BE READY AT 9:00."
- Yaya: I'M CONFIDENT.
YOU KNOW, I'M WINNING
ALL THESE CHALLENGES.
I CAN DO IT.
Ann: EVERYONE THOUGHT
I'D BE GONE A LONG TIME AGO.
I'M GONNA STAY LONGER THAN YOU,
EVA, AND YOU'LL SEE.
Norelle: DO MY PONYTAILS
LOOK RETARDED?
THE COMPETITION
IS REALLY STARTING NOW.
ANY LITTLE THING
WILL SEND YOU HOME.
IT'S STRESSFUL.
YOU REALLY HAVE TO GIVE
EVERYTHING YOU HAVE,
BECAUSE YOU WILL GO HOME.
Yoko: GOOD MORNING,
AND WELCOME.
TODAY, YOU WILL BE GRADED
ON YOUR PARTICIPATION
IN A TRADITIONAL JAPANESE
TEA CEREMONY.
A FAMOUS JAPANESE KIMONO
DESIGNER, KYOKO HIGA,
PROVIDED THESE KIMONOS
THAT YOU WILL BE WEARING TODAY.
THE WINNER OF THIS CHALLENGE
AND A FRIEND
WILL BE TREATED
TO A JAPANESE HOT SPRING.
Amanda: OH, WOW.
Yoko: SO GOOD LUCK.
Amanda: I'M EXPECTING TO WIN
THE TEA CEREMONY CHALLENGE.
I WILL BE APPROACHING IT
WITH A LOT OF REVERENCE.
Norelle: YAYA AND AMANDA,
THEY'RE TAKING IT,
LIKE, DEAD SERIOUS.
THEY REALLY, LIKE,
REMEMBER IT PRECISELY.
THEY ARE JUST SO, LIKE,
OOH--WAIT, OSAKI-NI.
I ALWAYS THINK OF, LIKE,
OLD SOCKS AND BIKINIS.
Eva: WE'RE DRESSED UP
IN KIMONOS,
AND THROWN TO THE LIONS,
BASICALLY.
Eva: WHAT?
WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE?
THEY WERE SO, LIKE,
PROPER AND UPRIGHT.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
Yoko: EVA--
SHE MADE A MISTAKE.
Eva: OSAKI-NI.
Yoko: SHE NOTICED
THE ORDER WAS DIFFERENT.
Eva: I'M, LIKE, LOOKIN' OVER
TO THE LEFT TRYIN' TO SEE,
LIKE, IF THEY SEE ME.
I LOOKED SO SUSPICIOUS.
TEA IS A GREEN, FROTHY,
NOT ENJOYABLE.
IT HAD LIKE LITTLE BITS IN IT.
IT'S JUST WEIRD.
TEA'S NOT SUPPOSED
TO TASTE LIKE THAT.
Yoko: ANN--
MAYBE SHE'S VERY TALL.
SHE SIT DOWN ON BLACK LINE.
THAT'S A MISTAKE.
WHEN SHE DRANK TEA,
SHE DRINKS LIKE THIS.
SHE SHOULD RELAX HERSELF.
Yoko: AMANDA--
I FEEL A LITTLE BIT AWKWARD,
BECAUSE SHE'S NOT USED TO WALK
WEARING KIMONO.
Ann: DURING THE TEA CEREMONY,
I WAS ON EMOTIONAL SHUTDOWN.
I DIDN'T WANT TO CRY.
I KNOW THAT THIS TOP PART
IS GELATIN.
Yoko: MM-HMM.
Amanda: BUT WHAT COMPRISES
THE PURPLE?
Yoko: PURPLE...
Amanda: OSAKI-NI.
Yoko: AMANDA, SHE FORGOT
TO MOVE THE TEA BOWL
WHEN SHE SAYS OSAKI-NI.
Yaya: I FELT MOST RELAXED
IN FRONT OF THE SCROLL.
APPRECIATING THE FLOWER,
TAKING THAT BREATH...
(breathes deeply)
THAT MOMENT WAS
JUST REALLY CALMING.
Yoko: YAYA FORGOT TO WIPE
THE RIM OF THE TEA BOWL
AFTER SHE DRANK TEA--
THAT'S A MISTAKE.
Yaya: I WAS OVERWHELMED
WITH THIS FEELING OF...
(breathes deeply)
WOW.
Norelle: IN THE TEA SERVICE,
THERE WAS PEOPLE
I'D NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
EVERYONE'S STARING AT YOU,
AND THEY WERE PROBABLY,
LIKE, PROFESSIONAL AT THIS.
SO I FELT LIKE, "OH, MY GOD."
Yoko: NORELLE--
HER BOWING LOOKS VERY AWKWARD.
WHEN NORELLE TOOK
THE SWEETS,
SHE USED THE PAD OF
PAPER UPSIDE DOWN.
NOBODY MADE THAT MISTAKE BEFORE.
Yoko: SHE COULDN'T--
THE PICK DROPPED.
Yoko: NORELLE DIDN'T DO
VERY NICELY ACTUALLY.
Amanda: IT'S TRULY MAGICAL.
Ann: I'M ENJOYING IT
VERY MUCH.
Eva: I LOVE IT.
JAPAN IS GREAT.
Yaya: (speaking Japanese)
I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE.
Man: HOW ARE YOU ENJOYING
YOUR TIME IN JAPAN?
HOW ARE YOU ENJOYING YOUR TIME?
Norelle: OH, IT'S DIFFERENT,
BUT IT'S A LOT OF FUN.
THE WEATHER IS, LIKE,
HARD FOR ME TO ADJUST TO
AND THE FOOD, TOO,
BUT, UM, I LIKE IT.
Yoko: THE WINNER IS...
YAYA.
Eva: YAYA ONCE AGAIN.
IT'S A CONSPIRACY.
Yaya: AMANDA,
WOULD YOU COME WITH ME?
Amanda: (giggles)
Amanda: YAYA'S WON,
LIKE, FIVE TIMES.
MORE POWER TO HER,
'CAUSE I'M SHARING
IN THE FRUITS OF HER LABOR.
Amanda: YAYA AND I
WENT TO HAKONE HOT SPRING SPA.
IT WAS SO NICE
BEING OUTSIDE THE CITY.
(humming)
OH, FLOWERS!
Yaya: KONNICHIWA.
OUR GUIDE TAKES US
TO THIS HOT SPRING.
THIS IS OUTDOORS.
IT'S A NATURALLY HEATED SPRING,
AND IT GOES DOWN
INTO THIS KIND OF STONE TUB.
GET IN, GET IN, GET IN.
Amanda: AH.
OH, WAIT, THE TOWEL!
Amanda: WE'RE THE YIN
AND THE YANG, MAN.
Yaya: (laughs)
Amanda: WITH SUCH A SMALL
NUMBER OF GIRLS,
AND BEING TOGETHER
FOR THE PERIOD OF TIME
THAT WE HAVE BEEN,
YOU'RE FINDING OUT
WHO'S REAL AND WHO'S NOT.
IT'S NICE TO BE RELAXING
AND AWAY FROM THE NOISE
OF THE OTHER GIRLS.
Eva: ANN'S LIKE,
"WHY ARE YOU SO QUIET?"
THE ATMOSPHERE CALLS
FOR A CALMING PERSONALITY.
THIS ISN'T A TIME TO BE LAUGHING
AND LOUD
AND JOKING AROUND,
TO ME.
Ann: I NOW DON'T KNOW
WHERE I STAND WITH EVA
AS A FRIENDSHIP, BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW WHO SHE IS ANYMORE.
Norelle: MODELING
IS A LOT MORE DIFFICULT
THAN I EVER IMAGINED.
I'M NERVOUS,
BECAUSE I STILL DON'T FEEL
LIKE I'M THE STRONGEST GIRL.
BUT YAYA COULD WIN EVERY SINGLE
CHALLENGE THERE IS AND NOT BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Yaya: CAN WE TAKE A MOMENT
AND APPRECIATE THESE BOWLS?
Amanda: YEAH.
AT LEAST WE APPRECIATE.
Yaya: YEAH.
Amanda: OH,
WE'RE EATING FROM YOU.
OKAY, I'M GONNA CRY.
(squeals)
Yaya: DINNER WAS FRESH,
FRESH, FRESH FISH.
MMM.
Amanda: THE BEST SALMON
I HAVE EVER HAD!
OH, MY GOD.
IT WAS INCREDIBLE.
IT WAS SO GOOD, AH!
Yaya: THIS MAKES ME
WANT TO STUDY FISH.
OISHII.
Amanda: WHEN WE GOT BACK,
WE ALL DECIDED TO GO OUT
AND HAVE SOME FUN.
(yells)
Yaya: WHOA.
Ann: ON THE ROOF,
THERE IS A SEPARATION.
LIKE, IT WAS FOUR OF US AND EVA.
WAIT, MOVE THIS WAY A LITTLE.
Eva: IT'S JUST
A VERY WEIRD ENERGY AROUND.
I'M NOT CLOSE
WITH OTHER PEOPLE IN THIS HOUSE.
IF I'D, LIKE, UNDERSTAND
WHERE THAT'S COMING FROM.
IT'S JUST, LIKE, SO PERSONAL.
- All: TO THE TOP FIVE.
- Amanda: TO TOKYO.
- Tyra: HOW'S EVERYBODY?
- Yaya: HI.
Amanda: SO TYRA WALKS OUT
IN THIS GORGEOUS DRESS,
AND IT WAS SO NEAT
BEING IN SUCH A BEAUTIFUL
LOCATION AND JUST SITTING THERE
RAPPING WITH TYRA.
Tyra: MY FEET HURT.
DO YOU GUYS MIND IF-- THEY HURT.
Eva: IT'S JUST SO MUCH MORE
RELAXING TO SEE TYRA
IN A DIFFERENT ATMOSPHERE
THAN PANEL,
BECAUSE SHE'S SO DOWN TO EARTH,
AND SHE'S SO COOL.
Tyra: GETTIN' THIS FAR,
I'M PROUD OF YOU GUYS.
Eva: IT DOESN'T
REALLY HIT YOU YET.
IT'S LIKE,
"OKAY, IT'S VERY REAL."
Tyra: DID YOU GUYS UNDERSTAND
BEFORE YOU GOT HERE THAT TOKYO
WAS A FASHION CAPITAL?
Yaya: I THINK
THAT'S SO AMAZING.
Tyra: I USED TO DO 20 TO 25
FASHION SHOWS IN PARIS EVERY
SEASON, AND ABOUT 6 OF THEM
WERE JAPANESE DESIGNERS.
OH, I'VE BEEN
IN SO MANY DIFFERENT PLACES.
I'VE BEEN ON ALL THE CONTINENTS
EXCEPT FOR ANTARCTICA.
AND FOR SOME REASON,
WITH JAPANESE CULTURE,
I FEEL SO CONNECTED TO IT.
OKAY, TO SAY, "I'M HUNGRY"--
THIS IS THE FIRST THING I LEARN
IN EVERY LANGUAGE--
IS ONAKA SUITE.
All: ONAKA SUITE.
Tyra: HOW ARE YOU GUYS
FEELING COMPETITION WISE?
Ann: I FEEL LIKE
I'VE SEEN ANOTHER SIDE
OF, LIKE, PEOPLE HERE.
Tyra: DID YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
TRUSTING GIRLS AT ALL?
ANY OF YOU GUYS?
A LOT OF YOU GUYS?
Ann: I HAVE TRUST ISSUES.
Tyra: I HAVE A CAMP FOR YOUNG
GIRLS-- IT'S CALLED T-ZONE.
ONE OF THE THINGS AT CAMP
WE TALK ABOUT IS SISTERHOOD.
AND BEING IN THE FASHION
INDUSTRY, YOU GUYS ARE GONNA
BE AROUND WOMEN ALL THE TIME.
JUST TO KIND OF HAVE
THAT RAPPORT ON THE SET,
IT MAKES IT SO MUCH BETTER.
Eva: IT WAS SO WEIRD,
'CAUSE I JUST SAID, YOU KNOW,
I REALLY DON'T CARE,
IT DON'T MATTER.
I'M IN THIS COMPETITION TO WIN.
AND AS YOU GET INTO IT,
YOU START TO CARE SO MUCH,
IT'S SICKENING.
LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
YOU REALLY DO CARE.
LIKE, EVEN WITH YAYA.
Ann: YOU THINK YOU MIGHT
BE FRIENDS WITH SOMEONE, AND YOU
DON'T SEE THE OTHER HALF.
Tyra: PEOPLE HAVE
SO MANY DIFFERENT LAYERS.
I ALWAYS SAY THAT THERE'S
NO SUCH THING AS A BITCH,
THAT THERE'S ALWAYS, LIKE,
A HURT SOUL UNDERNEATH THAT.
AND A LOT OF THE TIMES
WHEN WE'RE SAYING SOMETHING
NEGATIVE ABOUT SOMEBODY ELSE,
WE'RE TRYING TO COVER UP
SOMETHING INSIDE
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH.
WHENEVER I GET REAL "GOSSIPY,"
IT MEANS I'M BEING INSECURE.
AND I CHECK IT, 'CAUSE I'M LIKE,
YOU KNOW, "SHE'S GREAT.
"SHE'S TALENTED,
SHE'S GORGEOUS,
AND THAT'S WHY
I'M HATING RIGHT NOW."
'CAUSE I'M FEELING, LIKE, UH,
NOT SO STRONG, NOT SO GREAT.
I HAVE TO GO,
BUT I WILL SEE YOU SOON.
(French accent)
DO YOU LIKE THAT ACCENT?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS,
A LITTLE FRENCH, MAYBE, NO?
(normal voice)
BYE, EVERYBODY.
GIVE ME A HUG.
Eva: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Yaya: THAT CONVERSATION
WITH TYRA,
IT'S JUST VERY IMPORTANT
TO BE AWARE OF SISTERHOOD
AND TRUSTING OTHER WOMEN
AND HOW PEOPLE ARE ACTING,
EVEN IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE COMPETITION.
Amanda: BYE-BYE.
SHE'S PRETTY, PRETTY.
IN THE COMPETITION,
DRAMA IS ALWAYS THE SAME.
IT'S FINE FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS,
AND THEN SOMETHING HAPPENS.
Ann: IT HURT ME
AND IT HURT NORELLE THAT YOU
SAID THAT YOU HOPED SHE DID BAD.
Eva: SO HOPEFULLY SOMEONE
WITH... UP PICTURES... UP
AND THEY GO HOME.
Ann: ME OR NORELLE?
Eva: CLEARLY NOT YOU, ANN.
Ann: THAT IS... UP
THAT YOU WILL SIT IN THERE,
BE BEST FRIENDS WITH NORELLE
AND THEN TURN AROUND AND SAY,
"I HOPE NORELLE BITES IT."
THAT IS NOT EVEN RIGHT.
Eva: MY INTENT
WASN'T TO HURT ANYBODY.
Yaya: YOU GO AROUND
SAYING CONSTANTLY,
"EVERYBODY HERE'S FAKIN'.
I'M REAL.
EVERYBODY'S TWO-FACED."
YOU SEEM LIKE THE ONE PERSON
WHO EMBODIES THAT THE MOST.
Ann: I THOUGHT I KNEW
WHO YOU WERE,
AND I'VE SEEN SUCH A DIFFERENCE.
I DON'T KNOW
IF I LIKE WHAT I SEE NOW.
Amanda: WHEN THE LIONESSES
ARE HUNTING IN A PACK,
WHEN THERE'S A FLAW, YOU SEE IT,
AND EVERYBODY GOES FOR IT.
Ann: IT HURT ME
AND IT HURT NORELLE
THAT YOU SAID
THAT YOU HOPED SHE DID BAD.
THAT IS... UP.
Eva: MY INTENT
WASN'T TO HURT ANYBODY.
AND I DO APOLOGIZE FOR THAT,
'CAUSE THAT WAS VERY MEAN.
Norelle: JUST THE FACT THAT
OF ALL THE PEOPLE YOU COULD HAVE
SAID IT ABOUT IT WAS ME.
Eva: DEFINITELY.
AND IT'S WRONG,
AND THAT'S WHY I APOLOGIZED.
Ann: AND, LIKE, THEN I HAVE
TO WONDER, DO YOU SIT THERE
AND GO TALK TO HER ABOUT ME?
Eva: YOU'VE SAID SOME...
SO DON'T EVEN.
DON'T EVEN.
Ann: I HAVE NEVER--
Eva: DON'T EVEN.
- Ann: ONCE SAID THAT.
- Eva: YOU'RE SO LYING.
Norelle: I WAS SO CONFUSED.
PINK POSITIVE, WHAT'S GOING ON?
ARE WE GONNA GET DIVORCED?
Ann: NO, NO, NO.
Eva: I'LL TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THAT LATER, OKAY?
Ann: NO, NO, NO, YOU WON'T.
IF I SAID SOMETHING,
I WANNA KNOW WHAT I SAID.
Eva: YOU'VE NEVER SAID YOU
DON'T THINK
NORELLE'S PRETTY,
AND YOU DON'T LIKE HER LOOK?
Ann: WE TALKED ABOUT
HOW SHE HAD A DIFFERENT LOOK.
Eva: NO, ABOUT HER SIZE,
ABOUT HER WAIST.
Ann: SHE HAS HIPS.
NORELLE-- I MEAN, SHE HAS
A BIGGER MIDSECTION.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT,
TO ME, IS FACTUAL.
Norelle: OH, MY GOD. MY ONE
FRIEND WANTS ME TO GO HOME.
MY ONE FRIEND THINKS I'M FAT.
Ann: FOR YOU TO SAY THAT
AND SIT THERE,
IT'S JUST LIKE, I'M NOT--
- Eva: YOU HAVE SAID SOME...
YOU SUGARCOATED IT FOR HER.
Yaya: LIKE, SERIOUSLY,
YOU REALLY WANT TO MAKE ME
STUDY PSYCHOLOGY MORE.
Eva: HONESTLY--
Yaya: I'M CONTINUING TALKING,
ACTUALLY, 'CAUSE I'M TALKING.
THE BITCH OF THE HOUSE,
ANYBODY COULD SAY
THAT IT IS YOU.
Eva: WHAT DOES
NORELLE'S SITUATION HAVE TO DO
WITH YOU, YAYA?
SHE FEELS LIKE
I'M HER COMPETITION.
SHE EVEN SAID IT TO ME.
WE'RE BOTH SHORT,
WE'RE BOTH BLACK,
AND THERE YOU GO.
Ann: IN L.A., WAS THAT YOU,
OR IS THIS YOU NOW?
BECAUSE IT'S TWO TOTALLY
DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
Eva: FOR ME TO DO ONE THING,
AND NOW I'M A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT PERSON?
I THINK ANN KNOWS I'VE BEEN
NOTHING BUT A FRIEND TO HER.
AND SO FOR HER TO BRING
THAT SITUATION ON THE TABLE
WITHOUT TRYING TO UNDERSTAND ME
OR TRYING TO CLEAR IT UP,
IT'S LIKE, WHOA.
THAT'S-- YOU VERY WHACK
RIGHT NOW, HOMEY.
LIKE, YOU ARE SO WHACK.
I GUESS SHE NEVER DID KNOW ME
FROM THE BEGINNING.
Amanda: TYRA MAIL.
"BUST OUT FROM THE OLD,
EMBRACE THE NEW, GET READY
"TO WALK IN MY FOOTSTEPS.
BE READY TO LEAVE AT 8:00 A.M.
IN THE MORNING."
Norelle: WE'RE GOING TO DO
A PHOTO SHOOT TODAY.
AND I'M ALWAYS NERVOUS,
BECAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT IT'S GONNA BE.
- Jay: HEY, Y'ALL.
- All: HEY.
Jay: TODAY,
WE'RE GONNA PLAY WITH A THEME
THAT'S MODERN/TRADITIONAL.
SO YOU'RE DOING THE SHOOT TODAY
FOR T-MOBILE, OKAY?
BUT EVERY SHOOT, I FEEL LIKE I'M
CONSTANTLY TELLING YOU ABOUT,
"WHEN I'M WITH TYRA, SHE DOES
THIS AND SHE DOES THAT."
SO TODAY, IT ONLY MAKES SENSE
THAT IF WE'RE SHOOTIN'...
(all cheering)
Jay: WE GOT HER.
Tyra: I'M GONNA BE DOING
A PHOTO SHOOT TODAY,
AND YOU GUYS ARE GONNA BE ABLE
TO WATCH ME.
AND WHILE I'M SHOOTING,
I'M GONNA BE COACHING YOU
AT THE SAME TIME.
Jay: THAT'S GONNA BE TOUGH,
BECAUSE I'M SURE
SHE'S GONNA BEAT Y'ALL.
Tyra: THE COMPETITION.
Jay: I WANT YOU TO MEET
YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY.
SHE'S REALLY, REALLY TALENTED.
HER NAME IS AMIKO.
Tyra: AMIKO.
Amiko: HI.
(speaking Japanese)
Tyra: YOU GUYS READY?
- All: YEAH.
- Tyra: ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO.
Yaya: I'VE REALLY BEEN
WANTING TO SEE TYRA ON SET.
TO SEE HOW SOMEONE
WHO HAS BEEN IN IT FOR SO LONG,
AND WHO'S BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL,
IS A GREAT, GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
Norelle: LAST NIGHT, WHOA,
WHAT HAPPENED?
Tyra: AFTER I LEFT?
Yaya: YEAH.
Tyra: WHAT'D YOU DO?
Norelle: ME, EVA AND ANN
ARE, LIKE, PINK POSITIVE.
WE, LIKE, CLICKED THE MOST
WITH EACH OTHER AND WE HAVE
SINCE THE BEGINNING.
AND EVA HAD SAID THAT SHE HOPED
I DID BAD SO I WOULD GO HOME.
AND THEN EVA WAS LIKE,
"OH, YEAH, ANN?
WELL, YOU THINK NORELLE'S
UGLY AND FAT."
Tyra: WELL, NORELLE,
YOU'RE ONE OF THE TOP FIVE.
AND YOU HAVE TO REALIZE THAT'S
WHAT MAKES BEAUTY INTERESTING
IS WHEN IT'S DEBATABLE,
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE
THAT SAY,
"OH, TYRA BANKS IS BEAUTIFUL."
AND THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE
THAT SAY, "TYRA BANKS HAS
A BIG-ASS FOREHEAD,
AND I THINK SHE'S UGLY."
ONE THING YOU GUYS HAVE
TO REALIZE IS THAT EVERYBODY
TALKS ABOUT EVERYBODY.
IT'S ABOUT
WHERE IT'S COMING FROM.
IS IT COMING FROM AN UGLY PLACE?
IS IT COMING FROM JUST
A CHATTER PLACE?
IS IT COMING
FROM A HELPFUL PLACE?
BUT EVERYONE
TALKS ABOUT EVERYONE.
I'M TALKING ABOUT BEST FRIENDS,
TOO, DO YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
Eva: I WAS WRONG,
AND I SAID SOMETHING
THAT I SHOULDN'T HAVE EVER SAID.
ME WISHING YOU GONE,
AND ME WISHING YOU NOT HERE,
AND ME WISHING YOU BAD,
IT ISN'T LIKE THAT.
IT WAS MORE JUST--
MORE MY INSECURITIES.
IT WAS NOT EVEN THINKING
WHEN I SAID IT,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
SO I APOLOGIZE, LIKE,
FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART.
Norelle: I'M NOT GONNA CHANGE
THE WAY I THINK ABOUT YOU
BECAUSE YOU MADE ONE STATEMENT.
LIKE, FOR A SECOND,
I WAS LIKE, "OH, WHY WOULD SHE
SAY THAT ABOUT ME?"
BUT, I MEAN, IT WASN'T
THE MOST TERRIBLE THING, LIKE,
'CAUSE I DIDN'T THINK OF IT
THAT YOU REALLY WANTED ME TO GO.
AND I THOUGHT, "OH, MAYBE
SHE WAS JUST FRUSTRATED."
Eva: WE MIGHT NOT BE
AS CLOSE AS WE WERE BEFORE,
AND THAT'S FINE.
Norelle: YES, WE ARE.
EVERYONE'S LIKE, OH, MY GOD.
I WOULD TELL YOU OFF AND I WOULD
DO THIS AND I WOULD DO THAT.
BUT I DON'T CARE.
I LOVE EVA TO DEATH
REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAPPENS.
Tyra: HELLO!
WHAT I'M GONNA BE DOING
ARE VERY STRONG POSES.
KIMONOS ARE VERY DRAMATIC.
WE DON'T WANNA WASTE
ALL THIS DRAMA ON BORING POSES.
YOU GUYS HAVE TO CONSTANTLY
KEEP ON THINKING ABOUT
WHAT THE CAMERA IS SEEING.
Eva: IT WAS AMAZING FOR ME
TO SEE HER, LIKE, WHOA.
Tyra: SOMETIMES EVERY FACE
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE PRETTY.
I'M GONNA EXPERIMENT.
IT MIGHT BE REALLY UGLY,
BUT I JUST DID IT
FOR A COUPLE OF THOSE FRAMES.
Tyra: YOU GUYS
HAVE TO CONSTANTLY THINK
ABOUT YOUR LINES.
IF I DO THIS,
SHE DOESN'T REALLY SEE THAT.
BUT THE MINUTE I DO THIS,
THE CAMERA CAN SEE THAT.
Jay: OH, GREAT.
Tyra: I DON'T HAVE
THE MOST MUSCULAR LEGS,
SO I HAVE TO ALWAYS
PUSH SOME TENSION INTO IT.
Norelle: USUALLY AT MOST
PHOTO SHOOTS, WE'RE CONFUSED
AND PRETTY SAFE IN OUR POSES.
TYRA IS, LIKE, NONSTOP POSING.
Eva: TYRA MUST HAVE TAKEN
AT LEAST 50 FRAMES,
AND EVERY SINGLE FRAME
WAS DIFFERENT.
IT WAS AMAZING.
- Tyra: ALL RIGHT.
- All: YAY!
Tyra: IT'S YOU GUYS'
TURN NOW.
Jay: GET BACK TO HAIR
AND MAKEUP.
Amanda: ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO.
Jay: TODAY, THE PHOTO SHOOT
REALLY IS ABOUT GEISHA ESCAPE.
BY CHANGING UP THE HAIR,
THE MAKEUP AND HAVING
A T-MOBILE PHONE IN THEIR HANDS,
IT'S KIND OF MODERN
MEETS TRADITIONAL.
Jay: THAT TURNING ONE
WAS GREAT.
IT WAS JUST,
YOUR MOUTH WAS OPEN
AND YOUR EYES WERE HALF CLOSED.
AMANDA--I THINK SHE TRIED TO
PICK UP A LITTLE BIT OF TYRA,
BUT SHE'S JUST NOT GETTING IT.
DON'T MAKE YOURSELF DIZZY.
Jay: DON'T LOSE YOUR NECK.
AND LOOK UP AND INTO THE LIGHT
AS WELL FOR ME.
NO.
Jay: IT'S JUST--
IT'S TOO SQUAT.
Yaya: (gasps)
Jay: BUST THE PRODUCT.
- Yaya: OKAY.
- Jay: OH.
Norelle: WATCHING TYRA
JUST MADE US SEE HOW VERSATILE
WE COULD REALLY BE.
JUMP AROUND, PLAY AROUND.
Jay: THINK LIKE
YOU'RE A PRINCESS.
JUST PRETEND
YOU'RE IN YOUR PALACE
AND YOU ARE THIS ORNATE PRIN--
DID YOU EVER SEE, AT LEAST,
"ATTACK OF THE CLONES--
STAR WARS"?
LORD.
RAISE ONE SHOULDER AND MAKE IT
A LITTLE MORE GRACEFUL.
WELL, YOU'RE NOT GETTING IT.
TRY AND FEEL IT.
THESE GIRLS NEED SOME GRACE,
I SWEAR.
NOW BRING SOME INTENSITY,
SOMETHIN'.
Jay: THERE WE GO.
IT'LL BE REALLY INTERESTING
TO SEE WHAT ANN DOES TODAY.
AFTER WATCHING TYRA AND KIND OF
FEELING TYRA'S ENERGY,
MAYBE SHE'S GOT SOMETHING
FOR US.
RELAXED
WITHOUT PURSING YOUR LIPS.
JUST CLOSE YOUR MOUTH.
CLOSE YOUR MOUTH.
CLOSE YOUR MOUTH
WITHOUT PUSHING THEM OUT.
THAT ONE SHOULD LOOK GOOD.
MAYBE THE NEXT ONE.
EVERY WEEK WHEN I WORK WITH ANN,
I JUST KIND OF GIVE UP.
SHE'S JUST STUCK.
I MEAN, YOU COULD DO THINGS
THAT ARE JUST GRACEFUL.
DID YOU EVER SEE "MY FAIR LADY"?
PLEASE TELL ME YOU SAW THAT
AT LEAST.
CHILD.
Ann: YOU SEE TYRA MOVING
AROUND AND BEING CRAZY,
THEN IT'S LIKE I GET ON THERE
AND IT'S, LIKE, NOT LIKE THAT.
Jay: AND THEN JUST TIP YOUR
HIPS UNDER FROM THERE.
HOLD YOUR TUMMY IN,
IN A GRACEFUL WAY,
NOT A LINEBACKER KIND OF WAY...
SERIOUSLY.
CAN WE SEE THE OTHER HAND
A LITTLE?
AND DO SOMETHING GRACEFUL
WITH THE HAND.
Jay: OKAY, EVA, YOU GOTTA
STEP THIS UP TO THE PLATE.
I WAS TRYING TO SHOW ANN
A LITTLE BIT OF GRACE,
LIKE THIS POSE NO ONE'S YET
BEEN ABLE TO GET.
OH, THAT'S PRETTY.
Amiko: THAT'S NICE.
Jay: EXACTLY, GIVE ME--
YEAH, OH, YA FELT IT.
SHE'S LEARNING.
EVA WAS ALWAYS AWARE
OF THE T-MOBILE PHONE
AND HER BODY, EVERYTHING.
ALL RIGHT, EVA.
YOU'RE WORKIN' FOR THE CHILDREN
AS IF THE RENT IS DUE TONIGHT.
OH, THAT'S GOOD.
Amanda: TYRA MAIL.
Ann: "TOMORROW YOU'LL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY FOUR OF YOU WILL CONTINUE
ON IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"--
Norelle: "ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED."
(all laugh)
Norelle: FOUR GIRLS ARE
EVENTUALLY
GONNA HAVE TO GO HOME.
AND I WOULD WANT NOTHING MORE
THAN NOT TO BE
ANY OF THOSE FOUR GIRLS.
Eva: I CAME INTO THIS
COMPETITION WANTING TO WIN.
I'M GONNA LEAVE IT
WANTING TO WIN--
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
Ann: I WANT TO STAY
LONGER THAN EVA.
HONESTLY, I WANT EVA
TO BE ELIMINATED.
- Tyra: HELLO, LADIES.
- All: HELLO.
Tyra: IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGING PANEL
TO MAKE OUR TENTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER TO FINDING OUT
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NOW, OF COURSE, WE HAVE
SOME LOVELY PRIZES.
YOU'LL RECEIVE
A MODELING CONTRACT WITH A TOP
INTERNATIONAL MODELING AGENCY--
FORD MODELS--
A PHOTO SPREAD
IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE SHOT BY
WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
NOW, OF COURSE, WE HAVE OUR,
WHAT JUDGES, JANICE?
Janice: GORGEOUS.
Tyra: WE HAVE THE LOVELY
JANICE DICKINSON.
Janice: THANK YOU.
Tyra: NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
NOLè MARIN, A PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND STYLIST.
Nolé: HEY, LADIES.
Tyra: AND, OF COURSE, WE HAVE
A GUEST JUDGE THIS WEEK.
THE LOVELY FASHION DESIGNER
KYOKO HIGA.
KYOKO CREATES BEAUTIFUL KIMONOS.
THIS WEEK, YOU WILL BE EVALUATED
ON YOUR PHOTO, AND YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE A TEST,
WHICH NOLè WILL ADMINISTER.
Nolé: YOU'RE GOING TO WALK
FOR THE JUDGES.
Tyra: IN A KYOKO HIGA DESIGN.
YOUR WALK HAS TO BE FASHIONABLE,
YET RESPECTFUL
ACCORDING TO LOCAL CUSTOMS
AND ETIQUETTE.
ARE YOU READY?
AMANDA, YOU'LL BE FIRST.
Tyra: I LIKED
THAT YOU HAD A PROP.
OUT OF NOWHERE, THIS FAN SAID,
PSHAH!
BUT TO ME, YOU FELT
A LITTLE BIT WOBBLY.
Janice: I THOUGHT
YOU WERE DELICATE,
LIKE THE BONSAI BUTTERFLY.
Tyra: YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE MODERN MET TRADITIONAL
WHILE MODELING A T-MOBILE PHONE,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
Janice: OH, THE KIMONO
IS HEAVEN.
Nolé: STRONG POSE,
IT'S VERY STATUESQUE.
LOOKS REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
Tyra: THE PHOTOGRAPHERS
COMMENTS--SHE SAID THAT YOU
NEED TO GAIN MORE PERSONALITY--
YOU WERE TOO TIMID.
Nigel: AMANDA, YOU LOOK
CONFUSED BY THAT COMMENT.
BUT I'VE BEEN SAYING THIS
TO YOU.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET
OUT OF YOU IS THAT SPARKLE
THAT MAKES A PHOTOGRAPHER
INTERESTED AND INSPIRED.
Tyra: ANN.
Kyoko: SHE IS WALKING
VERY POWERFUL.
WHEN SHE WEAR JEANS,
IT'S OKAY.
BUT THIS IS KIMONO.
Janice: OH, THOSE HANDS
AND THE ARMS.
THE STATUE OF LIBERTY
LOOKS BETTER.
Tyra: LET'S SEE THE CLOSE-UP.
Janice: HER MAKEUP
IS FANTASTIC.
Nolé: THAT SHOT
IS FLAWLESS.
Nigel: EVERY PHOTOGRAPH
CAN'T BE JUDGED ON THE CLOSE-UP.
IT'S THE WHOLE PACKAGE.
Tyra: YAYA.
Nigel: YOU'RE GONNA BE
ONE OF MISS KYOKO'S FAVORITES,
'CAUSE YOU SHUFFLED VERY WELL.
MY ONLY CRITICISM--
I SAW VERY LITTLE YAYA.
Tyra: I REALLY
DIDN'T LIKE THE FACT
THAT YOU CHANGED YOUR HAIR.
IT TOOK AWAY
ALL THE FASHION ASPECT OF IT.
Janice: CAN YOU PULL THE PINS
OUT AND BRING WEST MEETS EAST?
- Tyra: THAT'S GREAT.
- Nolé: THAT IS SO BEAUTIFUL.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY, YAYA,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nolé: IT LOOKS LIKE
A BONSAI TREE.
THERE SEEMS TO BE A LEG MISSING.
IT'S JUST TOO ROUND
AND CUMBERSOME.
Tyra: HAVING SUCH
A FLAT FOOT LIKE THAT,
MAKES YOU LIKE FIVE-FOUR.
Nigel: YOU'RE TRYING
ALMOST TOO HARD.
IT NEEDS TO BE
MORE NATURAL FEELING.
MAKE IT FLUID.
Tyra: NORELLE.
Nolé: YOU LOOK
COMPLETELY SICK.
YOU LOOK LIKE--AS IF
YOU WERE GONNA PASS OUT.
Nigel: MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
APPEARANCE, WHEN YOU HIT
THE CATWALK, IS PERFECTION.
Kyoko: SHE LOOKS VERY NATURAL
IN THE KIMONO.
AND HER POSE LOOKS COMFORTABLE.
I LIKE.
Tyra: WOW, I LIKE IT.
Nigel: YOU LOOK LIKE
A JAPANESE CARTOON CHARACTER.
QUITE AMAZING.
Tyra: BECAUSE OF ALL
THE STRONG POSING, I THOUGHT
YOU WERE GONNA BE
A LITTLE AWKWARD.
BUT I'M PLEASANTLY SURPRISED,
AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
Norelle: THANK YOU.
Janice: PHOTOGRAPH--FABULOUS.
WALK--HORRIBLE.
Tyra: EVA.
Janice: I DIDN'T FEEL
THAT THERE WAS ANY GRACE
TO YOUR WALK AT ALL, AND YOUR
EYES WERE WAY OUT IN SPACE.
Nigel: I DON'T KNOW
IF THIS IS A HARD WEEK
FOR YOU OR WHATEVER,
BUT YOU LOOK SLOPPY,
A LITTLE DOWN.
Tyra: YOU SEEM SAD.
ARE YOU SAD?
- Eva: YES.
- Tyra: TELL ME WHAT IT IS.
WHAT IS IT?
YOU THINK THE COMPETITION'S
GETTING A LITTLE TOO TOUGH
FOR YOU?
Eva: I GUESS FOR THE ONE TIME
IN THIS COMPETITION
I HAVE FELT DRAINED.
NOT TIRED, BUT JUST SPIRITUALLY,
YOU KNOW?
I'M DEALING WITH IT.
Tyra: THE WINNER OF THIS
COMPETITION'S SCHEDULE
IS GONNA BE CRAZIER
THAN YOUR SCHEDULE NOW.
Nigel: YOU ONLY
HAVE TO TURN IT ON SOMETIMES
FOR 10, 15 MINUTES.
THE OTHER GIRLS,
IF THEY SEE YOU'RE DOWN,
THEY MAY PLAY ON THAT.
Janice: SHE BROUGHT IT HOME,
EVERYBODY.
Nolé: YOU LOOK LIKE A MODEL,
SOMEONE WHO IS WORKING
EVERY ELEMENT.
YOU, BASICALLY, REALLY
PAID ATTENTION TO TYRA.
IT'S AN AMAZING SHOT.
- Tyra: I LIKE THE TOE POINTED.
Janice: I DO, TOO.
Tyra: BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
ONE OF THE TALLEST GIRLS HERE.
THAT'S PROBABLY ABOUT FOUR MORE
INCHES OF HEIGHT THAT YOU
ARE GIVING TO THE CAMERA.
I THINK IT'S GREAT.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE JUDGES
TO DELIBERATE.
AND THEN WE WILL CALL YOU BACK
AND DETERMINE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
Tyra: AMANDA.
Kyoko: THIS PICTURE
IS FANTASTIC.
Nolé: AMANDA IS FIERCE
IN A PHOTO.
BUT SHE IS NOT FABULOUS
IN PERSON.
Nigel: SHE'S VERY QUIET.
SHE'S NOT MUCH ENERGY.
Janice: I DISAGREE.
I REALLY LIKE AMANDA.
Tyra: ANN.
Janice: ANN THE MAN
CERTAINLY LOOKS LIKE A MAN
IN THIS PICTURE, WHOO-HOO.
SHE HOLDS THE CELL PHONE LIKE,
YOU KNOW, IT'S A FOOTBALL.
Nolé: THAT CAN BE SEXY,
THOUGH.
Nigel: I THINK THERE WAS A LOT
OF THINGS ABOUT ANN WHICH WORK.
Janice: NAME ONE EXCEPT FOR THE
HAIR AND MAKEUP IN THIS PHOTO.
Nigel: WHEN ANN WALKED DOWN
THE CATWALK TODAY
AND SHE WALKED TOWARDS US,
SHE HAD A GLINT IN HER EYE.
SHE LOOKED POSITIVE, AND I WAS
LIKE,
"OKAY, ANN, YOU'RE
DOING YOUR THING."
Tyra: I THINK ANN
SHOULD GO HOME.
WHEN I WAS MODELING
IN FRONT OF THE GIRLS,
I THOUGHT
I WAS MODELING FOR ANN.
YOU CAN JUST DO A MONKEY SEE,
MONKEY DO.
AND ANN DID A MONKEY DON'T.
NORELLE.
Kyoko: I THINK
IF SHE COME TO JAPAN,
SHE WOULD BE POPULAR.
Nigel: UNFORTUNATELY, THIS IS
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND I THINK THAT WE'VE SEEN OVER
THE WEEKS THAT--
I DON'T THINK THAT SHE HAS
A FACE FOR AMERICA.
Nolé: NORELLE, THIS EVENING,
UNFORTUNATELY, REALLY
WAS VERY UNATTRACTIVE TO ME.
BECAUSE SHE LOOKED WET,
SHE LOOKED GREASY.
Tyra: I THINK NORELLE IS LIKE
CONFUSED AND SCARED,
AND KIND OF DOESN'T KNOW
WHY SHE'S HERE.
Tyra: LIKE,
"DAMN, I'VE MADE IT THIS FAR.
"WHY DO YOU LIKE ME?
'CAUSE I DON'T EVEN
LIKE ME YET."
NEXT IS YAYA.
Nigel: THIS PICTURE
IS A DISASTER.
Nolé: I KNOW YAYA
CAN DO MUCH BETTER THAN THIS.
- Tyra: EVA.
- Nolé: IN THIS PICTURE,
EVA IS ABSOLUTELY FLAWLESS.
HER POSE IS VERY
FASHION FORWARD.
Tyra: I WAS ROOTING FOR EVA,
AND I LOST A LOT OF THE LOVE
THAT I HAD FOR HER TONIGHT.
YOU GOTTA KNOW HOW TO GO HOME
AND CRY TO YOUR MAMA
BUT SHOW THE WORLD A GREAT
AND HAPPY FACE.
Tyra: I HAVE FIVE
VERY BEAUTIFUL WOMEN
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE FOUR PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE FOUR OF YOU
THAT ARE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL--
AMANDA.
THIS WEEK YOU WERE
VERY STRONG.
BUT ONE THING THAT THE JUDGES
ARE NOTICING IS THE PERSONALITY
IS SLIPPING AWAY.
THERE WAS A FEISTY, FUN GIRL
THAT WE MET IN NEW YORK,
AND WE WANT HER BACK.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Tyra: YAYA.
YOUR PICTURES FROM WEEK TO WEEK
ARE SOME OF THE STRONGEST,
BUT THIS ISN'T SO STRONG.
BUT WHAT IS THE STRONGEST
THAT I HAVE SEEN FROM YOU TODAY
IS YOUR APPEARANCE.
TODAY IS THE FIRST DAY
THAT YOU LOOK LIKE A MODEL
IN PERSON.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Tyra: THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL--
EVA.
EVA, YOU'RE STANDING BEFORE ME
BY THE SKIN OF YOUR TEETH.
YOU LOST IT TODAY.
YOU WALKED IN HERE,
AND I WAS LIKE, "WHAT HAPPENED?"
BUT WHEN AMERICA'S LOOKING
AT YOU, THEY'RE NOT THINKING,
"WHAT HAPPENED?"
THEY'RE THINKING ABOUT
THE NEXT GIRL.
LEAVE YOUR PROBLEMS AT THE DOOR.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Eva: THANK YOU.
Tyra: WILL ANN AND NORELLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE YOUNG LADY
THAT IS STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL'S NAME I DON'T CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO YOUR HOME,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND LEAVE.
THE JUDGES HAVE BEEN DEBATING
ABOUT YOU TWO FROM WEEK ONE.
ONE OF YOU IS VERY
STRONG-LOOKING IN PERSON.
ONE OF YOU IS STRONG
IN HER PICTURES.
PEOPLE WANT TO SEE A FANTASY.
THEY WANT TO ESCAPE
WHEN THEY LOOK AT A PICTURE.
YOU HAVE TO DO INTERVIEWS.
YOU HAVE TO DO
PERSONAL APPEARANCES.
AND PEOPLE WANT TO SEE A GIRL
THAT LOOKS LIKE SHE DOES
IN HER PHOTOS.
SO THAT'S THE BIG DEBATE--
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT
TO TAKE AN AMAZING PHOTO,
AND HOW IMPORTANT IS IT
TO LOOK STRONG IN PERSON?
I'M NOT SURE IF THAT QUESTION
HAS BEEN ANSWERED TONIGHT,
BUT SOMEBODY HAS TO GO.
Tyra: ANN.
Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS.
Tyra: YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
- Ann: THANK YOU.
- Tyra: THANKS, NORELLE.
Norelle: I'M
SO PROUD OF MYSELF.
LIKE, I MADE IT TO THE TOP FIVE,
AND I DIDN'T EVEN THINK
I WAS GONNA MAKE IT,
LIKE, TO A CALLBACK.
THIS EXPERIENCE HAS MADE ME
SO MUCH MORE DETERMINED
TO BE A MODEL.
I'M PRETTY GOOD AT THIS,
LIKE, BETTER
THAN I THOUGHT I WOULD BE.
SO IT'S HARD, 'CAUSE YOU
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO WIN,
AND ALL THE GIRLS,
LEAVING YOUR FRIENDS.
I'M GOING STRAIGHT HOME
AND STRAIGHT INTO AGENCIES,
LIKE ONE AFTER THE OTHER.
I'M NOT GIVING UP.
LIKE, I'M NOT DOING THIS,
AND I'M NOT CRYING
'CAUSE, LIKE,
I'M SAD OR ANYTHING.
LIKE, I WILL BE A MODEL.
I WILL BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'M OKAY.
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
Tyra: COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
THE GIRLS GET A CRASH COURSE
IN NAVIGATING
THE STREETS OF TOKYO.
Eva: WHAT DOES THAT SAY?
IT'S NOT ENGLISH.
Tyra: AND YAYA STRUGGLES TO
KEEP UP WITH THE COMPETITION.
Ann: YAYA'S NOT EVEN HERE.
Tyra: ANN PULLS OUT
ALL THE STOPS TO PROVE HERSELF
IN THE PHOTO SHOOT.
Jay: THERE YOU GO.
I LIKE THAT INTENSITY.